- On this show, I talk
about dropping F bombs,
getting clients, and why
I'm in such a bad mood.
(hip hop beat)
I am Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching the #AskGaryVee Show,
Episode 17.
Little fun fact about the number 17,
it is my Grandma Esther's
and Xander's birthday,
the 17th.
Before I get into the
show and start answering
these five great questions,
two video, three regular,
I just wanna say that I'm
in an enormously bad mood
because the Jets blew an
18 point lead yesterday.
I appreciate all of you that
were interacting with me
as I was judging Miss America yesterday.
You might have noticed that
my energy level was down.
My energy level on this
episode will be down in general
as well because I'm still recovering.
And, you know, the hard core Vayniacs
who watched Wine Library
TV back in the day
remember these kind of Monday episodes.
For a lot of you newbies, you're
not going to be used to it
but you need to take, just
like my wine fans did,
which was take the scores I gave the wine,
and add one or two points
because they knew I was
in a depressed narrative.
You guys may want to
take some of the advice
on this episode as a,
with a grain of salt.
Maybe, DRock you could put
like a warning sign here.
Warning, warning, warning.
I'm pissed off and today's
answers might be just OK.
- [Voiceover] Darren asks,
"If you could only market
on one social platform,
which would it be and why?"
- Darren, I picked this
question because I'm pissed off
and I'm pissed off at
people asking this question
over and over again.
I'm pounding my fist on
the floor, or the table.
Over and over, this is a non debate.
It is Facebook, my friends, Facebook data.
Data, data, data, data.
Let me say it again, as
somebody who doesn't love data.
Who's more EQ than IQ.
The overwhelming accuracy
of who you are targeting
and the products that they have created
to target those people,
including in stream,
not the right side of a website.
So I'm over here, I
like how you're staying-
Go back there, DRock.
Not the right side of a website,
but right down the pipe.
In the feed, targeted properly,
and if you're a good enough marketer,
and you're putting out
content people care about,
not an ad, and we all see ads.
No.
A piece of content.
And I know people are tired
of the word content, great.
Call it stuff, I don't give a crap.
Just something people
care about in there when,
you know Steve, show Steve.
You know Steve likes Reddit.
You know Steve likes-
Back.
You know Steve likes wine.
You know, you know he likes these things.
What else do you like, Steve?
- Cheese, video games.
- [Gary] Great, what else, Steve?
- Beer. I love beer.
- So, you know, give this
man things of those nuances.
If you're a toilet paper or
a toothbrush or a toy company
or a, you know, what is this?
This is a phone, you
know, technology company.
Like give this man what
he wants around the genres
he cares about.
Facebook is, by far, dark posts.
That's a terminology.
Unpublished posts, the best
platform to be selling things,
doing business, getting
money for your charities,
building awareness about your cause.
Facebook, Facebook, Facebook, Facebook.
- Hey, Gary.
Nicole Delanzo here from Taste Daily.
I love the new series.
So, for the past 18 months,
I've been delivering
daily emails to a community
of thousands of women.
And this fall, my
startup was getting ready
to launch its first product.
It's interactive workshop,
called Victory Rituals,
where we flip the morning
routine on its head.
As we go from concept to final product,
what's the best way to empower our readers
to help us spread the word
about Victory Rituals?
Look forward to your thoughts.
- You got it, Nicole.
I like how you positioned that, Nicole.
How could we empower our readers
to spread the word.
What you mean is,
how do we get our readers
that we've been able to amass,
to spread the word so
we can get more people
into our funnel and sell
this thing, which is great,
because we are talking
about business here.
Two ways, there's only two ways.
And everybody saw lovely
Nicole ask the question.
And she was very politically
correct, in my opinion,
and structuring it properly.
But what you're basically saying is,
I've amassed an audience and
now I want to sell them stuff
and not only do I want to sell them stuff,
because I feel like I'm entitled
to because I've given them
a bunch of free content on email
over the course of these
last couple of months,
or year, Nicole, how
you've been doing it, plus.
But I also want them to not only buy,
but then I also want
them to spread the word
so other people buy.
There's only two ways to have
the audacity to make that ask.
And that's what that is, my friends.
You can be doing a daily email
and putting out great content.
You could be putting out
a great show, every day.
But then you come to that moment.
A book, a something.
And there's only two ways to convert.
Number one, write a good book.
In your case, Nicole,
your product needs to be good.
Is it worth the $38?
Is it worth the $83?
Is it worth the $388?
Is it worth the $883?
There used three and eights in there
if anybody was paying attention.
So, first and foremost,
the best way to convert
and empower them, aka have
them push it on to others,
is by putting out something
great that they want
to tell other people to use.
They valued it more than they paid for it.
Number two is good old fashioned honesty.
You just need to be
really upfront with them
of what you want from them.
You want them to share your video.
You want them to go to your website.
You need to be upfront with the fact that
here are the things that you want.
And so, for me, it's
putting out a great product
that's worth the money.
And number two, not
hedging your right hook.
Just asking for it, like a woman.
- [Voiceover] Dan asks,
"What's your process
for vetting clients,
specifically at VaynerMedia?"
- Dan, answer number one.
Do you have enough money?
Dan, answer number two.
What I'm really looking
for, to not make a joke,
and you know, this show's putting
me in a better mood, guys.
I gotta be honest with you.
I forgot that that's what
Wine Library TV did for me
on these Mondays where I want
to annihilate people's souls.
Putting on a show with my
community does help my feelings.
I need a lot of comments on
this episode, by the way.
I need comments in there.
I need, I need, comments.
Anyway,
you know, the things
we're looking out for is,
are they creative?
The number one thing I'm scared of is
we have a ton of creativity
and we can do real work.
But if people want to
follow a very strict process
of how they've always done it
versus how we're supposed to do it.
I'm petrified in that.
So really there's no way to do it,
because everybody says
they want to be innovative
and do the new thing and
invest in the future.
And then you get into practicality
and the first thing
that's cut is the future,
which is why so many people lose.
So everybody's into defense versus offense
when times get tough.
For me, when times get
tough, you go harder,
not eh.
Anyway, so I'm trying to sniff out
if people have the
stomach to be innovative
and do things differently.
To take some risks, but be practical,
but have a little more
patience for that practicality
and that ROI to present itself.
- Gary, I've got a very
serious question for you.
- Hey, Brian.
- How the (bleep) do you
get away with saying (bleep)
so many times on stage
and not catch a bunch
of (bleep) flak for it?
- Brian, as the CEO of an
up and coming IPO company,
I'm very impressed with your
audacity to ask that question,
which leads to my very simple answer,
which is two fold.
I think the reason I get
away with dropping the F bomb
is number one, I mean it when I say it.
There's no tactic.
I'm just in the zone.
I mean, I was inspired by
Richard Pryor and Chris Rock
and Eddie Murphy and their
styles have translated
to my keynote styles.
I feel like I do a little bit
of a stand up timing process
and I think that because
I'm not forcing it
and because it's my natural zone,
a little Jersey boy action,
people respect authenticity.
The other reason I'm able
to get away with it is
I don't care if I receive flak.
As a matter of fact, I use
the F bomb to vet people.
You know, I've said it before,
I'm gonna say it again.
We're gonna do it again,
another question coming up.
This is a platform for
me, for the hard core,
last seven years fans of
mine, for me to go one layer
deeper into things I've never said before.
The truth is I actually use
my F bomb to vet other people.
I actually react to the way
you're reacting to my F bomb
because if you are a person,
back to the last question,
that is so thrown off by
using the F bomb in public,
in a public setting, with a keynote,
that you're then not looking
at the big enough picture
for me, just my personal.
You're judging me, I'm judging you.
So if you are incapable
of getting over that
and seeing the bigger
statement that I'm creating,
well then you're not gonna be somebody
that I wanna do business with, invest in,
or take on as a client to begin with,
because you're at this micro level.
That's right, you're at this micro level.
And that's just not a
place where I wanna play.
I don't want to play in
the micro, so (bleep) you.
- [Voiceover] Seth asked,
"What was the hardest thing
when starting up
VaynerMedia from scratch?"
- Seth, you know this
is another place for me
to give a little bit of insight.
Believe it or not, yes, not
doing Wine Library day to day
with my dad.
Yes, the notion of
taking the risk of being
in another family business and
not ruining the relationship
with A.J.
Confident on both fronts.
The hardest thing was actually
being crippled by options.
The notion that over
the first nine months,
it was very difficult
for me not to think about
the fact that me and
A.J had 800 other things
we could have done and did
we pick the right thing.
I think a lot of people
who are watching this
are always crippled.
I get this a ton, which is
why I picked this question.
Well, I didn't pick it, you
know, Steve picked or we picked,
you know, how did we pick it?
- [Steve] This one was collaborative.
- This was a little more
collaborative, right?
You tried to give me a different question
and I said, "No."
No.
I like this one, because it
allows me to give an answer
to my audience that I see a
lot of you struggling with.
It's been asked of me a
ton on email, twitter,
and other places, which is,
at some point, you've gotta
put your big boy pants on
and say, "I've made this decision."
And you move on.
The buyer's regret or remorse,
or like, did I do the right thing?
Or crippled by options is
something so many of you
are struggling with.
And I struggled with it as well,
especially with all the
opportunities that I've been able
to be given.
I'm so fortunate that I'm
struggling with, like,
should I do a national TV show?
Should I extend the fund by 10 times
and do a quarter billion dollar fund?
Should I quadruple down on Vayner?
You know, I'm crippled.
I'm crippled by options, which
is a blessing and a half.
And so the hardest thing
was, in 2009, was like,
is this the right thing?
Don't forget, Vayner
started in 09, May of 09.
Misha was born in May of
09 and Crush It! came out
in October of 09.
So there was all those
other things going on.
The struggle, the hardest thing
was not starting the business.
It was second guessing,
was it the right use of
my time and A.J.'s time
and upside and talents at the time.
And that's it.
I'm pissed still.
I hate Packer Nation.
For a week, because actually
I don't have a problem
because we don't play each
other again for four years.
And the last time we were
at Lambeau we won 35 to 7
and that felt good.
But that was last time and
I know you're gonna say,
"What happened this time?"
And what happened this time was,
a lot of misfortunate things.
Misfortunate things that
really, really, hurt my soul
and my feelings that I'm
in a state of sadness
for the rest of today and
probably into tomorrow.
But by Wednesday, I'll
start gathering the momentum
to start focusing on the
Bears and Monday night.
And I will be there at
the game on Monday night.
You keep asking questions, I'll
keep trying to answer them.
Oh right, question of the day.
I don't know.
Just tell me about
yourself in the comments.
I just wanna read a lot of
comments from my community
and feel better so,
tell me something good.
And that's just not a
place where I wanna play.
I don't wanna play in
the micro, so fuck you.
(laughing)
(hip hop beat)